florentino o bienvenido y usted ha
examinado la sociedad japonesa con sus
golpes y sus dificultades pero también
con su capacidad de resiliencia
tras los hechos dolorosos como el
desastre de la planta de fukushima diez
años después está superado este dolor la
gente aún no quiere volver a la región
pese a los reportes de que la
radiactividad es mucho menor
efectivamente desgraciadamente hay que
decir que fukushima no es historia
es una pena decirlo pero si es verdad
entonces si se han considerado unas
cosas efectivamente se abrieron y además
escuelas muy bien dotadas para que la
gente volviera se han abierto casas se
han abierto pueblos etcétera y
efectivamente hay algunas gentes que han
vuelto no pero hay que decir que todavía
faltan muchísimas cosas por hacer por
ejemplo a ver dónde se van a poner los
restos de la radiación
hay que decidir eso precisamente donde
volverá gente hay algunas cosas algún
empezado a vaciar algo del el del ente
el de la energía que quedaba allí en
fukushima de los de los restos que había
pero fíjense me parece que estaba
leyendo el 2032 cuando se piensa que se
podría vaciar todo lo todos los
restantes peces
y sigue en varios pueblos además de que
todavía son inevitables y este desastre
profesor se conjuga con otro fenómeno
preocupante y es el envejecimiento de la
población más que en cualquier otra
parte de japón allí disminuye la
densidad poblacional y tiene la gente
razón en sentirse aún hoy en peligro por
la radioactividad de pese a informes
como el que vimos de la onu que dice que
cáncer de tiroides en los niños no
aumentó por el accidente de la planta
justo desde luego fíjense que desde el
principio la información que se dio en
japón fue muy carente de verdad se les
dijeron cosas precisamente para que
estuvieran demasiado tranquilos y la
cosa estuve normal en en este caso por
ejemplo la diferencia fue que se pudo
ver en televisoras si uno de los retos
es eso ahí por lo menos se pudo ver
claramente hay 90 pero si especial el
problema de la población de japón es muy
grave fíjense que hace cinco años fue me
parecen 126 millones habitantes
actualmente está bajando fíjense qué
las cifras más o menos son me parece 30
30 mil personas
digamos que mueren más de los que de los
que nacen entonces la situación en japón
está muy grave y precisamente el
problema es eso que solamente la zona de
tokio es la única que tiene aumento de
población todo el resto del país ha
bajado va subió un poquito la zona de
casa y la zona de kioto kobe y osaka
precisamente por gente venida de la zona
de tohoku no donde el accidente pero
efectivamente ahí hay un problema muy
granja con es el exceso de nazis perdón
el exceso
entonces aquí precisamente es uno de los
problemas pero fíjense que es un
problema para uno es decir japón lo está
experimentando antes porque japón apenas
ha tenido población inmigrante
pero esto es una cosa que no se está
moviendo todo no le digo el caso de
españa también porque el caso de japón
fue en 2016 fue el primer año en el que
tuvieron menos de un millón de asia vale
bien bueno en españa fue lo mismo que me
parece que hubo menos de dos mil
doscientos mil nacimientos en el año
2000 2019 pero claro en españa había
ocurrido 20 años antes en el año 1999 me
equivoco si no me equivoco pero lo que
pasa es que españa con la emigración
volvió a aumentar el número de el número
de nacimientos que ha ocurrido por hoja
los inmigrantes pues está pues en un
principio procrear más pero luego dejan
de prosperar y vuelven y se hacen
españoles como los demás entonces de
nuevo ahora la población española aún en
todos nadie los aumentar pero han vuelto
a declinar por debajo de los 200 mil
gracias es bien entonces fíjense osa la
situación es muy general es una cosa que
ocurre en todo el mismo